Jason Lacan for CBS Sports NFL insider
Drew Brees is injury Ben
Roethlisberger's injury or which one do
you think is looking worse oh I don't I
don't I don't know that you could answer
that just yet okay you know drew Brees
is is on a fact-finding mission I would
not be surprised if he gets more than
one opinion before he gets back with
some fate and then they figure out what
to do here whether a procedure of some
sort is inevitable whether there's some
sort of apparatus you know what I mean
it's some some kind of custom thing they
could get made for him that that maybe
could help him with the grip and take
some of the pressure off the thumb you
know they'll obviously explore any and
all options certainly doesn't sound like
he's going to be playing football this
weekend and it's probably going to be
Teddy Bridgewater's show at least for a
few weeks but they're still gathering
information and with Ben Roethlisberger
if he does require surgery then or not
that obviously is going to put a good
portion of his season at risk is that
something where rehab and recovery and
we can deal with with the elbow and any
issues with it that way you know that
that sort of remains to be seen but
there's definitely significant concern
in both those organizations about these
situations and well who's got a better
backup for surgery backup quarterback
situation the Steelers or the Saints
Bridgewater is obviously more
established experience you were just
talking about guys in the playoffs there
I mean we we saw him you know be a part
of a playoff win right or did they or
did they miss that field goal not like
you've won a game Jimmy he beat Seattle
at home anyway
been to the playoffs Mason Rudolph just
getting his feet wet I was intrigued by
what I saw Mason Rudolph under duress
down to Seattle they often said show
nothing through six quarters with
Roethlisberger been throwing to his wide
receivers this year and obviously it's a
big deal because that a B guys not in
there anymore and now juju has got to be
you know Batman and not Robin throwing
to his wide receivers twenty four forty
two hundred and four yards no touchdowns
one interception QB
54.6 throwing that any wide reciever not
named juju though QB rating goes down to
30 so it wasn't pretty there seemed to
be a spark to me from rudolph is that
sustainable you know what I mean was
that in just an initial sort of like you
know rush of adrenaline I don't know the
scouting community was split on him
coming out of school the Steelers liked
them a lot more than some other teams
did but the Steelers have also done a
really good job with offensive skill
players so I don't know I would expect
Mason Rudolph to be running that offense
for at least a few weeks but we'll know
a little more later today
what about the Giants situation and I
mean it's inevitable it's not a question
of if but when so when is when for the
Giants to make a change I mean I circled
like week six way back in the summer as
I kind of started plotting some of these
scenarios and looking at team schedules
and knowing I didn't see a scenario
where the Giants were going to be a
viable football product this year you
know they they were one of the eight
teams that I would have thought back
after the draft was going to be one of
the eight worst teams in the league and
he kind of looked at the league divided
into quarters and the bottom quadrant
they would have been there for me in
March they'd have been there for me in
July they're still there for me now but
this is a different situation right
because it's about the mythology of Eli
and Eli's place in the organization and
the Manning name and there's you know
and how they botched it though you know
with Geno Smith playing the one game in
Oakland and then going back to Eli so
there's a lot that goes into this and
it's obviously there's an ownership
component to it so it may drag out
longer than most sort of outside
football people would think it should
because of all that Dan but but you're
right it is inevitable I can't imagine
it gets passed into the second half of
the season right like I don't don't know
how that's like how you could really
start making that argument you know week
nine week ten does it happen before then
it it I don't know how they avoid it I
really don't I mean at some point you
got to let this kid come in at least
play in the second half if you're
getting blown out and give him the whole
second half and
shows that he signs a life that's it
yeah but I think I think they're worried
he might be good and then and then you
have to upsell I know it's awkward you
gotta just do you say hey they kid look
good and we got to do this we're talking
to Jason welcome for a CBS Sports NFL
insider Antonio Browns accuser meeting
with the NFL does he have to speak to
the NFL I would most certainly think so
and Drew Rosenhaus has said that he'll
cooperate with with any and all
investigation so that that has to
include team willing I was think to talk
to the league I guess where it goes
beyond that though is sort of the real
nebulous area here because I'm not sure
other than those two individuals that
there's going to be many others who can
speak to the exact nature of their
relationship as it pertains to these
allegations and at this point there
there is no criminal paper trail there's
nothing in the courts you know there's
no police records there's there's no
there's no infinite reports there's
nothing else to go on so I will see you
know what everybody at Park Avenue
decides there and and what all is at
their disposal but obviously in the
meantime he's going to be a member of
the New England Patriots unless they
find something to the contrary that that
the league believes should result in him
being either suspended with pay through
the exempt list because that's really
what that is or just plain suspended
Jason good to talk to you as always we
appreciate your time my pleasure
Jason luck and for CBS Sports NFL
insider yeah so Antonio Browns accuser
gonna meet with the NFL today that's
quite a honeymoon she got married over
the weekend and then you gonna fake
Asian honeymoon in new New York for more
Dan Patrick show tune in to audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV stream for free
on BR live or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]